Now what if I want to have--
you know--I want to have text up here--here in the Dropdown--
but I want to have a different parameter up here in the URL.
You know--that's useful when you want
to have more descriptive text here.
The way to do that is to use the Value parameter.
Let's look at that in the Editor.
Here we are in the Editor--you can see our elements
and elements the way we left them.
I'm going to add a Value parameter to this first one.
And it's value is going to equal "1"--
the number, "1"-- instead of the string, "one".
Let's go ahead and make these a little bit longer.
Our first value in the Dropdown--or our first element in the Dropdown
now has a value equal to the numeral, "1"
and contents of the words, "the number one".
All right--let's see how this looks in our browser.
So now we can see our Dropdown has changed.
The first element says, "the number one"
and the other two are the same as they were before
as they were before because I didn't change those.